welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm Benjamin Dixon David Pakman is away
Bernie Sanders you know in the Bernie
Sanders doesn't have a middle name so in
the primaries I gave him a middle
initial of F Barney effing Sanders has
pushed and pressured Amazon so much that
this morning Amazon has announced that
they are raising the minimum wage for
all of their US workers all of their
employees some 250,000 individuals to
$15 an hour now we should just take a
minute to applaud the efforts of Bernie
Sanders and everyone in the progressive
movement who have insisted that this is
the bare minimum that people need to
live in this in America I mean I think
it still only adds up to about $28,000 a
year for a full-time employee
so I mean take it from me or he'll take
it for you that's not enough that's not
a lot of money but for a person who
works full-time for a person who who
gives 40 hours a week I mean that's the
least that we should be doing for if
you're making trillions of dollars but
let's get to the specifics and this is
from CNBC this is what they said quote
Amazon announced Tuesday it's raising
the minimum wage for all US employees to
$15 effective next month the new minimum
wage will benefit more than 250,000
Amazon employees including part-time and
temporary employees as well as another
150,000 100,000 rather seasonal
employees the company said some
employees who already make $15 per hour
will also see a pay increase according
to CNBC now to let you know why I mean
you should hopefully most of you already
know about Bernie Sanders is activism
with regard to Amazon and targeting them
like a laser which I he absolutely was
right in doing but I want to read a
tweet from Bernie Sanders a recent tweet
and then as well as read about a piece
of legislation that he introduced
Bernie Sanders said this on Twitter he
said quote Amazon is worth one trillion
dollars Jeff Bezos
is worth 155 billion thousands of Amazon
workers have to rely on food stamps
Medicaid and public housing to survive
that is what triggered that is what a
rigged economy looks like tomorrow we
would introduce a built-in subsidies for
low-wage employers now to give you a
little background on that legislation
that he introduced it was called the
stop Bezos bill named the stop bad
employers by zeroing out subsidies or
the stop Bezos act after Amazon founder
Jeff Bezos Sanders's bill would levy a
tax on large companies equal to the
value of the public benefits that their
workers received he argues that if
employers paid a living wage taxpayers
would save 150 billion a year on the
government assistant programs including
food stamps Medicaid and public housing
now I want you to pause and think about
this it's not just Amazon companies like
Walmart and and McDonald's they have
they pay their employees so little so
little that they have to get on food
stamps and public assistance and
Medicaid in order to survive so we are
literally subsidizing sharecropping
we're subsidizing slave labor in this
country where an individual gives 40
hours a week and they are doing exactly
what this capitalistic society is
demanding of them and yet they're not
given enough to survive when CEOs of
these companies make more in one second
than some of them make in a year now
that might be hyperbole but I'm sure I'm
not that far off if you do the math they
may make it may take a minute it may
take a minute for Jeff Bezos to make as
much money as an individual makes in an
entire year that makes his company work
and this shows you that there's an
entire breed of of capitalists as well
as politicians but there's an entire
group of individuals who want no
responsibility to this society they
simply want to withdraw all of the
benefits and all of the wealth that they
can get out of the society without ever
paying in it
back they don't want to pay back into
our infrastructure they don't want to
pay back into any social programs for
the social good for the for the common
welfare they don't want to invest in
anything they will gladly invest in they
want the government to invest in the
military because investing in the
military means investing in defense
contractors which is just another
capitalistic venture but they don't want
any responsibility to the government to
this to the society rather from which
they derive all of their wealth they
want to be able to take everything and
give nothing back to us and what they
would pay back into the society would be
in the form of Taxation and so now we
see we're getting I mean what stage of
capitalism is this when when you have
all sorts of people I mean hundreds of
thousands of people if you take all the
if you take wal-mart and McDonald's
you're talking probably close to a
million workers who have to get on
government assistance because their
corporate lords don't pay them enough to
even live on the feudal land that
they're tilling this is the kind of
society that we are quickly going to and
even $15 an hour is not enough but since
you know they did capitulate they
acquiesced a little bit you know good on
you Amazon but now obviously we're gonna
demand more we're gonna demand more from
Walmart we're gonna demand more from all
of these companies that make trillions
of dollars now off of slave wages in
this country and thanks to Bernie
Sanders for leading the charge on this I
mean seriously
a lot of people try to slam Bernie
Sanders for this specifically but his
actions have led to a direct material
benefit for a quarter million
individuals in this country nobody else
was doing this nobody else in the Senate
nobody else in the I mean he had
supporters right I know Nina Turner was
side by side there's people all you know
all types of activists who have been
calling for the same thing so the Bernie
Sanders is not alone in this but he led
the charge and while he was leading the
charge you had obviously Republicans
attacking him but you also had Democrats
attacking him and P
even using this as a means of explaining
why it was so good that he lost the
primaries but what have you done
you know everybody who slammed Bernie
Sanders what have you done to have a
measurable positive material impact for
the good of 250,000 people and now we're
getting ready to go for more miss me
with all that Bernie Sanders would have
won today's program is sponsored in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman if you've
not already heard about blink Asst it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n